Today's topic England, if you aren't aware in this recent last few days,
England played in the finals. Uh, this is the euros, basically the, uh,
top football teams across Europe compete.
The final two was England versus Italy, and it's a big deal.
All the English people thought that the trophy was coming home.
The Italians had something else to say, and in a very close game,
the Italians won on penalties and it was heartbreaking for a lot of English
people, uh, for the rest of the world. There was a joyous moment.
We all celebrated. It's hard to know where to start with this story.
There's a lot of moving parts for me personally, watching it.
I'm a huge football fan. I've been watching most of my life.
I know all the Americans look oh, a Rob name. Yeah, whatever. Okay, cool story.
I think why this store became,
I think more than what it was is the three individuals who missed their
penalties, um, were three young black men.
And after the final had finished and the whistle had sounded and English once
again lost, which sent a lot of people into, uh, feeling extreme sadness.
A lot of, uh,
racist verbiage was hurled at them on social media having missed those
penalties. So, uh, now everyone's talking about it,
talking about the aftermath, talking about the disappointment,
the fact that it's not coming home, meanwhile,
everyone else is enjoying their pasta and meatballs. So, well,
I think when there's like a unified cause and everyone's winning,
I think it's easy to all come down under the same banner and feel a sense of
unity. I think, uh, unity gets tested when things get a little bit difficult.
And as you saw in the loss, um, I think the people,
a lot of people were very congrat, very impressed, uh,
happy with how far they got, even if they were disappointed, went home very.
And then there's some people who decide to break down barricades,
attack Italian fans and take things a bit too far. Um,
and I don't think that's a reason to be disappointed. It's like, well, you know,
the cause ended, it's hard to constantly feel that together.
And it's a very difficult thing to maintain with so many people.
You're always gonna have outliers who are going to engage in rowdy behavior as
far fans go, you know, interestingly enough, this one,
I think the racial component didn't stand out to me too much.
I know this about sports fans.
There's always gonna be a group of them that are incredibly toxic.
It doesn't matter what your race is. Gender background, ethnicity.
You could be a white dude. And if you up in a key moment,
don't say death threats, your family, you, everybody around you.
I know another countries they've killed refs for holes. He didn't like,
they've done. Listen,
you just wear the wrong Jersey to a different spot and people will stomp you
out. What it really comes down to. But people like, you know, it's sports.
It comes with a territory. And I think, I think that's why I draw the line.
I think where, what gets things,
there are individuals who are such babies who are so immature,
who can't handle, not getting their way,
that in the wake of that decide to cause destruction, just to give other people,
um,
that sense of helplessness or to rid themselves of that feeling of helplessness.
You didn't get your way. Guess what? There are like a dozen, 15,
20 other countries who also didn't get their way.
The way these championships are set up. Only one team gets to win. Yes,
you came close. But part of being a grown person,
being a mature adult is accepting when things don't go your way.
And the truth is there's a lot of grown men who act like babies when they don't
get their way, they get violent, they get routed, they got liquor in them.
They're disappointed. They're angry.
They're around other guys who are disappointed, angry, and they act like idiots.
They act like dangerous idiots. And it's unfortunate for the young players who,
you know, bar those mistakes at the end, you know? And,
and honestly you can really say, this is a problem for a manager.
If you want to get into like the technical aspect of football,
the they're receiving so much. And some people say, well, it comes to territory.
You make all these millions. It's like,
is that the kind of world we want to foster where we just tolerate that kind of
stuff. And thankfully,
a lot of social media platforms are coming together to create filters in order
to be able to filter out the people who send messages like that.
And I agree with procedures like, but I think what I took away from all of this,
we wanna know preach. What, what did you.
Think about everything? I saw the stories and I saw the, the, the,
the slurs and stuff. And I was like
football. I'm not, we've been talking about that for ages,
you know, monkey, Chan football players, having banana thrown at them,
bananas, thrown at them while they were playing
Mo and monkey noises and stuff like that. I mean,
it's been happening. They have a group that are rowdy,
like there's fans, and then there's hooligans.
They gave you a name I'm from a different era. Maybe,
maybe like a, from a different era, a little bit older than Abba right here.
And you know, at some point, you know,
hooligans were wearing bummer jackets and stuff like that.
And duck Martins back in the days, you know what I mean? It was very linked.
It was weird. It was a weird time. You know what I mean? Worse than patriotism.
It it's, it's, it's something else. I don't know what it is,
but it's something else. It's it goes over being a fan. But yeah,
it comes with slurs. I'm not saying that all the fans are doing that. No,
but it's there. We can't deny that it's there. It is not there.
We can't say that. It's not there. It's there. It's obviously there,
I've seen it in. You've seen it. And it's not even in England, I'm saying, yeah,
England. It's not even England.
I've seen those racial slurs everywhere.
I think that even if it was three black people from Italy that
would've missed the penalty shots,
I think the same thing would've happened by LA was talking about having his,
his experience with the, it's not just an English thing.
I'm not even thinking it's a soccer thing. Maybe it's a European thing.
I don't know. But it's there it's been there, no matter the country, you know,
I'm gonna say it like that.
Every Europe country has they either they
either they black or they're from Arab descent or they are
Roman. Everybody has someone that they teach lead,
treat like dirt and to them is dirt to them and whatever, whatnot, that's above,
above football and in soccer,
whatever you call it, kickball, whatever. It's a problem it's been there.
I don't know if it's an England thing. I don't know if it's a soccer thing.
I don't know if it's a European thing, but it's there. Definitely.
So we'd like to be like, yeah. English people. Yeah, because ithappened to you.
But it happens everywhere. It's crazy that they,
they just got all the hate they got for playing.
Cause sometimes when you're gonna play, you're gonna win.
And sometimes you're gonna lose. You're gonna miss shots. What's a, it's up.
If you think about it, if you take it out of its contest, it's like, yo,
you're getting all this hate all these racial hate just because you were playing
a game and, and, and playing the game.
Losing is part of playing that game. Yeah.
And the people that were rowdy and disappointed that they were doing this and
the people that were doing are the people in the worst shapes ever, bro,
you're talking anyways, whatever.
I think it's oversimplifying it. You know, when it comes to sports,
there's storyline, there's culture, there's heritage, there's emotion,
there's lottery, there's community, all these things intertwine.
It's not just a game. It's not just a, a moment. It's, uh,
it's a chance to create a history and um, to witness something special.
And I think that's why people rally around sports.
It's one of those things that we could all come under one banner and all witness
something to get. I understand all.
That. Also.
What people will say, like, I understand why the emotions is so charged.
I understand why people get,
we can't say it's just a game when people get that depressed.
I understand. But what, what I'm talking about is, is he played the game.
He went in there and he is he's,
he's having basically his life trend because he received that stress and stuff
like that. So I understand that there's a legacy that comes to that. I,
I understand that, but it doesn't excuse it. Yeah.
I can understand how it gets charged like that, but it does not excuse it.
Right. And the day.
Right. You playing a game, I'm not, it is not just playing game though.
Like you can I say two things. You can say one, it doesn't excuse that behavior.
And also not minimize it to it's just a game because there's people who have
feeling all kinds of range of emotions around this event,
that it means something to them the same way.
You probably have things that are special to you.
That means something to you that people will be like, well, it's just an event,
but it's not that for you. Right. Mm-hmm <affirmative> our emotions,
the history, the story behind these things, they, they hide everything.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> right.
I know people who go to conventions for anime and to them,
you say it's just an event to them. It's like their, what?
They wait for their whole year. Right.
In that same token for something like this,
England hasn't won a trophy or made it to the finals, like 50 years for them.
It's, it's a top story line, right.
In that same token for most people in Myanmar, they're like, Hey,
we shooting each other. We're too busy. <laugh> see what I'm saying. Yeah.
It varies for everyone else. So that's a thing. It,
it was a lot for me to take in. I think a lot was happening. Uh,
and I think unfortunately,
a lot of the other stuff kind of distracts from what happened in the gang
because, uh, if English people, um, really paid attention,
they'd get rid of that manager who, who was really incompetent.
I don't care what nobody says. He's terrible at his job.
So those were my thoughts on it. I think there's a lot going on. Yeah.
Attacking people, beating them up. You know, I had a friend of mines, uh,
she got beat up in Denmark when England won,
she was wearing an English Jersey and people, the Danes beat her up.
And I was like, wait,
you wore an English Jersey to a Denmark bar during the euros in Denmark.
Yeah. She's like, I can't believe it. I was like, you couldn't believe it.
What are you talking about? If the Canadian era playing the brooms,
don't put no broom flag on your car. Yeah. Cops. Self-awareness like,
it's not right. But at the same time, be a little bit smarter.
It's crazy out here. So I have no solutions. It was just,
those were my thoughts during the whole thing.
So let us know what you guys think about what you saw.
How did you feel about the incidents in the commentary or about the performance
or about what this means for sports and sports Wigan? Um,
I think they have a long history. I think it's something to be gust.
I think it speaks to the psyche of group and mob mentality,
the euphoria sports, the euphoria of disappointment and, and,
and lashing out. That's I think what it's really about, you know,
whether it's like the, the Vancouver, when they lost the,
the NHL and they burned down the city. Yep. Right.
Or like how many times after a win or loss, do cities get burnt down?
It's crazy. There's something that happens when you're in a group, in a mob.
Yep. And everyone experiences something together.
I think that's what this story's really about. So let's know what you asking.
It's just a Brody Bo Mike.
No, nothing has to do
you call me when you turn and you on your other.
No. Now you wanna play
why you wanna be
the ones?
I be the one that keeps you calling. Gotta love that. I keep you calling.
I be the.